donc en fait moi je vais accompagner
monsieur sahuc passe quand on visite une
bibliothèque c'est mieux d'avoir un
guide
sinon on y passerait la nuit donc on va
aborder rapidement l'arrivée de monsieur
celle qu en afrique les conditions qu'il
a découvert quand il est arrivé ici une
partie des travaux rapidement qu'il a pu
faire en mauritanie et ce qui s'est
passé entre la décision de faire
nouakchott hong kong a évoqué les plans
de nouakchott les conditions de l'époque
est ce que de la théorie est devenue
aujourd'hui la pratique
donc voilà j'arrête de parler je vais
laisser monsieur saül parler donc que
vous êtes arrivés en afrique
en 1953 elle alors moi je suis arrivé le
9 mai 54 mauritanie à saint louis du
sénégal à renan de takhar par le chemin
de fer
je me suis retrouvé à une heure de
l'après midi sur le quai de la gare de
saint louis du sénégal
et là j'ai commencé à le mettre en
relation avec des autorités de la
mauritanie pour effectuer effectué ma
mission qui à l'époque était de faire
les études d'un chemin de fer entre
sourires à traîneau adibou pour
l'exportation du minerai de fer de jouer
rate donc je suis arrivé à saint louis
j'ai commencé à travailler le monde
pouvait travailler ça a été un ruisseau
à construire une route entre le bac de
rosso et le logement du commandant de
cercle de ressorts qui ne pouvaient pas
aller à son logement panard hivernage
parce qu'il y avait de la boue devant
cris a fallu construire nos hôtes pour
ce monsieur je fais ce travail là et
ensuite j'ai été commencé à travailler à
sur un aéroport à
bâillonner la trousse je suis allé à
laâyoune et la trousse pour construire
un terrain d'aviation qui à l'époque
était sur la route de nioro et qui était
inondée pendant l'hivernage
donc je suis parti deux avec tout le
matériel de saint louis je suis monté à
kayes et jeux de kayes je suis parti sur
un lionel à tous est arrivé à la
frontière est il du mal et je suis tombé
en panne des voitures parce que j'avais
un vieux 4,4 fargo codes de la de
l'armée américaine ou de 45 qui roulait
à 60 70 à l'heure à tout casser et qui
faisait beaucoup de bruit donc me voilà
tombé en panne en pleine nature à la
frontière du mali et j'ai dû attendre
trois jours qu'on vient de me repêcher
parce qu'il n'y avait pas circulation
entre lyonnais et kayes à l'époque et
c'est un camion de la société lacombe
qui m'a ramassé qui m'a amené à à kayes
et je suis reparti de kayes avec un bain
une niveleuse et je suis arrivé six
jours après à eux de la trousse pour
faire mon travail voilà seul était
heureux des bons j'ai passé 3 jours et 2
et 3 de 8 à adana nature avec un litre
d'eau voilà c'était ma première aventure
quittera bien venu et donc vous êtes
arrivé à nouakchott
je suis arrivé à nouakchott alors ma
première intervention en action ç'a été
un 14 juillet 1954
j'ai été chargé de faire l'analyse de
toute la route de nouakchott à 2,1 de
rousseau à nouakchott pour améliorer la
route pour desservir nouakchott
nouakchott
donc je fais j'ai fait le trajet de 2
ressort à à nouakchott à un voiture et
j'ai repéré toutes les carrières tous
les trains tous les trucs tous les
travaux tous les passages qui fait
d'améliorer j'ai fait un rapport là
dessus et c'est dans cette occasion là
que j'ai connu nouakchott en 54 mois de
juillet
voilà et quand est-ce qu'on vous
annoncer que vous allez travailler sur
nouakchott
alors j'ai commencé à travailler sur
nouakchott parce que après après avoir
fini les études du chemin de fer j'ai
travaillé pendant deux ans a réparé pour
m'occuper de la du tracé des chemins de
fer entre f d'eric et pour etienne à
l'époque
et puis j'ai fait on a fait six titres
assez nette ud6 tracé et on en a retenu
un qui est celui qui passe par shu et
qui reste en territoire mauritanien
parce qu'il fallait rester un territoire
mauritanien pour ne pas grever le projet
parce que l'espagne à la main à cette
époque-là demander des frais de passage
en territoire espagnol très élevé donc
pour ne pas crever le prochain on a été
obligés de rester à mauritanie et on a
fait un tunnel le tunnel de chaume le
fameux tunnel de chaume courbe qui
rentrent qui entre en territoire
mauritanien et reçoit rente est un
territoire mauritanien pour éviter la
frontière voilà alors je suis resté deux
ans là j'ai travaillé avec les goumiers
avec les militaires et avec tous les
gens qui s'occupaient de chemin de fer à
l'époque et on a étudié ce tracé du
chemin à faire et on a lancé les travaux
du chemin de fer en 62 2-64 retrait de
1961 donc nouakchott et donc votre
projet nouakchott si juste avant en fait
alors je suis arrivé à nouakchott à 58
par la sdat cette époque là pour
m'occuper des premiers travaux de la
capitale une capitale où il y avait
alors 7 de capital c'est le gouverneur
muraga l'époque qui a accédé aux désirs
du gouvernement mauritanien de
tran serait la capitale de saint louis
du sénégal sur un site mauritanien pour
que la capitale soit à mauritanie alors
il ya eu un conseil de l'assemblée
territoriale qui s'est décidé à 57 en
janvier 57 et qui a décidé de progrès
pour promulguer la nation la république
islamique de mauritanie et de tenir le
deuxième conseil du de l'assemblée
territoriale à nouakchott
c'est à la suite de ça que j'ai commencé
les premiers travaux à nouakchott
donc quand vous vous êtes arrivé à
nouakchott ce qui existait une
nouakchott c'était look ça c'est
l'ancien fort militaire
ben oui c'était c'était coppolani qui en
1903 avait amené par un bateau à roue à
aubes et là tout d'un un fort
préfabriqués qui l'a amenée ici il a
fallu faire venir des pirogues de
saint-louis d'ailleurs pour transférer
parce qu'avec la barre ne pouvait pas
décharger les bateaux dont il a déchargé
ça il a construit le premier fort en
décembre et janvier un descendeur 1903
et en janvier 1904 il a fait fort une
enceinte tout ça à l'endroit où se
trouve le château d'eau acte les morts
c'est là qu'ils étaient de ceux force
parce qu'ils étaient dominés la mer il
était à la hauteur et 17 mètres
cinquante la hauteur de trucs par
rapport au niveau de la mer et c'était 1
5 km de la mer et il fallait c'est le
point culminant de nouakchott quoi la
recette m 50
il serait de 50 l'écart entre le niveau
de la mer et le château d'eau actuel
d'accord et donc la première chose que
vous avez fait à nouakchott en arrivant
c'est un aéroport allemand châteaudun
construit le premier aéroport 59 points
avec l'aide de la société colas qui
était l'entreprise routière qui
travaillaient mauritanie à l'époque et
on a fait une piste pour les avions
d'essai trois de ses quatre à l'époque
de 1600 mètres de l'eau sur 45 m de
large avec un parti
un terre-plein pour les taxiways et tout
et on a fait une piste de 1600 mètres
pour a accès à faire atterrir des avions
de ces quatre à l'époque maire face est
femme se faisait la ligne entre dakar
avec des 2 et 4 à l'époque
ok donc avant de construire une ville il
faut faire des plans avant de construire
une ville il faut faire des plans oui
alors alors là on a commencé oui à
travailler sur le plan d'urbanisme de la
ville de nouakchott à partir de mars 57
il ya eu cinq plans d'urbanisme
d'étudier le premier c'était par fait
par le gouverneur albert nouragues qui
était gouverneur de la mauritanie à
l'époque et qui a proposé un plan très
si vous maîtrisez très géométrique avec
des rues comme ça avec le droit et une
place et tout ça c'est tout dans c'était
tout à fait succinct ensuite il ya eu un
deuxième plan qui a été exécuté par
monsieur hirscher monsieur hirsch
c'était le directeur des travaux publics
de la mauritanie à l'époque l'ingénieur
en chef déposé chaussée qui a été par la
suite directeur de l'école des ponts et
chaussées d'ailleurs que je connaissais
bien et d'huy a fait un plan plus c'est
d'abord et à s'adapter davantage au
terrain les lignes de force du terrain
et ainsi de suite donc ce deuxième plan
a été soumis au conseil des ministres et
n'a pas satisfait tout le monde et on a
fait appel à un monsieur la ville qui
était architecte de des bâtiments et
palais nationaux à dakar la rfa l'époque
à dakar et qui a remanié le plan hirsch
et qui a refait une proposition cette
proposition était faite
1 mais en avril 57 so lu ment est
absolument
voilà voilà voilà les trois plans
d'ailleurs ils sont là 1 2 3 et le plan
l'un vit le plan dans le plan cerutti
c'est pas l'avis de cerruti alors
cerutti a proposé un plan qui était
adaptée
courbes de niveau du terrain actuel et
qui a permis de faire un plan plus
adapté aux besoins de la mauritanie
ensuite il ya eu une quatrième
intervention c'est celle de monsieur
rainville qui a repris le plan cerruti
et qui a aménagé des années et qui a
fait 4 mars une masse pour les
ambassades et les logements sociaux
ensuite une un truc pour les les
ouvriers pour les les besoins des
chantiers et ensuite une autre pour la
verdure et pour les centres
administratifs
donc on a des idées fait une un plan qui
a permis d'être étudiée et d'être soumis
au conseil des ministres ce plan
l'invs il a été retouchée par le comte
cerutti des architectes qui avait été
choisi par le gouvernement mauritanien
pour finaliser le plan et blanc et à
cette époque là le plan le comte cerutti
a été adopté par le conseil des
ministres en février 59 et alors ce plan
là a été a été prêt à prouver et a été
mise à exécution
alors ce plan 1959 a été approuvée par
le conseil des ministres par le
gouvernement et a été décidée il a été
décidé qu'il ne soit mis en exécution et
on a commencé à travailler à partir de
ce plan sur les travaux à faire les
premiers travaux à faire pour faire la
capitale pourrait vous poser la première
pierre de nouakchott
alors martin on a posé la première
pierre de nouakchott de saint-marc 58
ans avait que monsieur gérard jacquet
ministre de la france d'outre-mer
française de l'époque et le général de
gaulle est venu d'ailleurs visité la
pierre en 59 2 12 10 décembre il est
passé ici
non on a posé la première pierre saint
marcel gilles massa mais le général de
gaulle est venue quand 59 alors on a
commencé par construire la capitale
alors il a fallu
la première des choses penser à à
l'alimentation en eau parce que pour
vivre à nouakchott il faut de l'eau
sinon on ne peut pas vivre
donc il y avait un gros problème d'eau à
l'époque à nouakchott
il n'y avait pas de d'adduction d'eau
n'y avait rien il y avait que des oblats
abela et à la palmeraie de bélaye de
twila qui donnait un fabre pas beaucoup
de cinquantaine au sein d'id par jour
s'étaient pas suffisament est alors à
cette époque là on avait construit trois
citernes de 800 mètres cubes chacune
pour récolter l'eau de pluie l'eau de
pluie sur le terrain d'aviation ont
récolté l'eau de puits pendant
l'hivernage qu'un petit pleuvait on l'a
mené dans les citernes et ça servait de
réserve d'eau pour toutes leurs chances
internes qui sont en face de la maison
de là il y en avait 3 qui était au
carrefour qui on a démoli la valeur en
points le grand rond point qui étaient
là bas qui arrivaient des dîners et dans
laquelle l'adduction d'eau des milliers
de déverser l'eau et il y'en avait deux
qui sont ici derrière le carrefour de la
mise derrière de la mer dont l'hôpital
mère et enfant dans l'enceinte de la
société sonelec et là il ya encore le
cij de deux grandes citernes qui sont
l'inde ou qu'ils sont blancs dont on se
servait de ses thons la faisait bouillir
et on vivait avec l'eau de pluie pour
assurer la soudure et quand il ya eu
cette des problèmes avant pour tout ça
on avait trouvé aussi un système avec
des appareils série ni qui sont des
appareils qui fava qui dessaler l'eau de
mer par thermo donc les premiers
bâtiments que vous avez construit
nouakchott c'est les trésors on a
commencé à construire la première
réduction de 1 59 mois j'ai fait la
première voie entre le terrain
d'aviation et l'hôpital actuel qui
n'existait pas à l'époque
l'avenue de la dune
ah bon j'ai fait certaines lois pour
ceux qui comprennent pas la rue de la
dune j'ai construit cette loi mais voilà
la vraie faille et voyez le pardon
monsieur sahuc on sorte je suis là c'est
là qu'étaient les citernes vous allez y
avait trois citernes ou 200 mètres cubes
là et il y en avait deux oksa pour
assurer le complément parce que les
trois n'étaient pas suffisantes
donc il y avait et quand vous avez fait
les travaux donc pour avoir l'eau des
travaux vous utilisiez les camions qui a
porté du qu'à l'oral
rires ça c'était pour l'alimentation
mais pour les gens et on nous paie un
peu tout pour les chantiers il y avait
un gros problème il fallait trouver 1600
mètres cubes d'eau tous les mois pour
assurer la fonction fonctionnement des
chantiers donc on a eu recours au
transport d'eau à partir d'ax juge avec
des camions de la souris mais la société
qui exclut le cuivre dax juge qui a mené
son carburant par camion-citerne jusqu'à
12 depuis nouakchott et un retour des
sondés à vide dont on remplissait on
nettoyait un peu lésé des canaux citerne
ou remplissez d'eau et on a mené de
l'odac juste pour faire les la soudure
pour les chantiers il faut se rendre
compte quand même que de construire une
ville un endroit où comme nouakchott n'y
a pas d'eau ça représente toute une
logistique complètement incroyable dans
le sens où aujourd'hui on est là on
ouvre notre robinet tôt à la limite on
oublie même qui coulait à l'époque quand
ils ont construit nouakchott
y'avait rien quoi donc c'est vraiment
cessé ses soeurs et d'un mouvement le
match s'est toujours posée mais on a la
certitude qu'ils avaient une nappe
phréatique très importante sur le
travail qui était alimentée par le fait
que le sénégal à partir de podor et qui
pouvait à fournir de l'eau en quantité
pour une ville importante jusqu'à 500
millions d'habitants pendant 50-60 à on
a fait des étudiants a déterminé qu'elle
pouvait fournir cette hausse est pour ça
qu on a commencé à construire une
première conduite un diamètre de 200 m
mm 20 cm en fibrociment à partir divini
les premiers forages étaient assez le
bagas ramello n'y avait que 15 mètres
d'épaisseur d'eau douce après il y avait
le france année dont on a été obligé de
reculer encore de 10 km pour avoir la
certitude d'avoir de l'eau pendant une
centaine d'années en grand quantité
suffisante pour alimenter une ville de
200 mille habitants voilà c'est à partir
de ces éléments qu'on a construit cette
conduite fille de 200 qui a amené mille
mètres cubes d'eau potable par jour à
nouakchott à à partir de 1905 1959
s'appelle ça permettait d'alimenter à
peu près tous les besoins de la
population
à l'époque il y avait en 58,5 1200 à
1300 habitants à nouakchott avec les
chantiers tout ce qu'on avait c'est ça
servait assez pour faire la soudure de
ain eau potable
g et quand on a eu des problèmes avec
avec le juge on est allé à rosso flins
va chercher de l'eau avec des camions
citernes pour alimenter les chantiers
finir de les échantillons qui avaient là
donc c'était ça bons premiers travaux
terrain d'aviation route entre le
terrain d'aviation et l'hôpital qui
n'existaient pas ensuite on a fait un
programme de voirie d'une dizaine de
kilomètres avec la colas moi je
participe à sa j'avais fait des études
et des travaux
ensuite on a commencé à construire
avant on avait déjà commencé à
construire en 58
les 13 premières vide là qui devait
servir à abriter l'assemblée nationale
la première assemblée nationale
territoriale 1,59
voilà on y est presque vide là elle sera
en face les blocs manivelle il ya la
senelec et même dans le siège il ya une
ruée de l'autre côté il ya cette 13 e
vide là où habitait avant particulier
m moktar ould daddah le président de la
première et qui étaient là à ce moment
là et qui habitait ce logement 1 et
ensuite on a commencé à construire les
blocs manivelle derrière 6e derrière les
blocks manivelle on appelle ça bloque
manivelle parce que ça fait la forme
d'une manivelle de voiture voyez est un
bâtiment l'inla est à l'aca fait forme
de manivelle pratiquement pas en théorie
un plan qui est posée une ville tu es
montée qui démarre qui débarque à ce
avec beaucoup de problèmes et tout d'un
coup ça tu as eu tous explose bas ça
explose pas mais sera plus vite il ya
beaucoup plus de rythme plus élevé
et là il faut beaucoup plus de moyens
beaucoup plus parce que le gros problème
c'est l essai de l'argentin il fallait
ajuster le financement qu'on avait aux
travaux pour pouvoir suivre et ne pas
avoir rupture de crédit d'ombré il a
fallu s'adapter on a étudié un plan de
financement au départ sur l'ensemble de
la capitale pourra voir tout ça et par
tranches on est arrivé à essayer de 2,2
de concilier les financiers et les
chantiers la ville a pris neuf cent
mille habitants 60 ans à ba oui un peu
plus ou un peu moins que moi plus ou
moins quoi je voudrais dire à 558 y
avait 5000 habitants avaient pressé 1200
après on est pressé en 80 il y avait
deux cent trente mille habitants ont
dépensé 18 mille mètres cubes d'eau par
jour 1 donc il fallait les trouvais
aussi il a fallu faire la deuxième
induction d'eau de vie ni avec un
diamètre de 70 cm de terre de diamètre
des conduites ces les chinois qui ont
fait 7 e cette adduction d'eau et qui a
servi pendant une dizaine d'années à
alimenter la capitale parce qu'on est
passé de 2,5 mètres cubes heures à 18
mille mètres cubes en 1981 et ça
augmente et ça augmente et est
actuellement en sort 150 mille mètres
cubes d'eau par jour pour alimenter la
capitale et tous les besoins qui a donc
ça fait beaucoup
c'est fait beaucoup alors il a fallu
travailler là-dessus faire un plan de
d'adduction d'eau conséquent en fonction
de tous les besoins et on allait arriver
à ce qui se passe aujourd'hui voilà et
moi donc on doit terminer en fait donc
je voudrais qu'on termine avec votre
conclusion en fait très personnel sur le
nouakchott d'aujourd'hui alors ce qui
était fait ce qu'il y avait ce qui
aurait dû être fait selon vous si
c'était à refaire
aussi c'était à refaire un poster ça
c'est une autre paire de manches et
parce que vraiment il y aurait beaucoup
de choses à dire et beaucoup de choses à
faire mais le problème c'est toujours
problème un problème de moyens si on a
vu au départ les financements rapide et
et en quantité qu'il fallait ça
s'adresse à aurait changé tout à fait
d'attaqué des choses on n'aurait pas
fait tout ce qu'on a fait un moyen de
succédané pour essayer de combler les
vides et détroussé tôt sinon la prépa
contrôler voilà donc maintenant je
voulais aussi tu es un fake
une anecdote fini trop bégayé truc c'est
que comme quand j'étais à mauritanie je
voyageais beaucoup et je faisais
beaucoup de kilomètres un chameau en
voiture en avion et un jour je me suis
retrouvé à tiji déjà avec un parcours en
fer entre tychy zhao yun en avion un
avion 1 sur un avion allemand jan caire
un vieux jean pierre de l'arn et 45,5
allemande là et gvt est un voyage avec
une dizaines de mauritaniens qui faisait
le thé dans l'avion alors j'étais assis
dans un coin et je suis prêt et je
voyais le feu dans le brasero qui a
allumé les étincelles et qu'elle est
partout a350 et l'avion que vous
où j'ai fait un parcours d'avion avec ça
mouille en buvant le thé dans un dossier
des tasers karam allemand car elle est
là bas et une autre fois j'ai fait un
voyage avec guy chabot dans un de ces
trois on avait embarqué des chameaux
pour les transporter 2 qui t'aident
d'apparat laâyoune j'ai fait tout le
trajet au milieu de dix charbon dans
l'avion des c3 qui allait jusqu'à demain
on va arrêter ici et vous remercie on
s'arrête là bas ça je fume cause du
temps ouais on a bien vu on n'a rien dit
ouais je voudrais moi j'ai j'en ai des
tonnes comme ça si nouvelle figure dans
notre coin
il faut être un autre micro tendu